welcome back to New rockstars and when
you've been laningham and the new Shazam
2 trailer just dropped this trailer has
a vastly different tone than the first
one that came out a few months ago where
the last trailer was fun jokey and
Blasting with Eminem music from 2002.
this new one is much darker and more
ominous watching this current version of
the trailer made me feel like I should
expect an entirely different movie than
the one that was advertised in the first
trailer so today I'm taking you frame by
frame to cover all the details you might
have missed we opened in the realm of
the Gods at what I believe could be
Mount Olympus or at least the dcu's
version of it next we see Lucy lose
Calypso wreaking havoc on Citizen Bank
Park home of the Philadelphia Phillies
after stepping down from the back of her
Dragon she plunges a golden apple into
the Earth causing gigantic roots to bust
out not only do we see these roots
destroy the Stadium seats and parking
lot they continue to extend along the
Benjamin Franklin Bridge rapidly growing
into the city when this intersection
gets wrecked paint the street signs
we've got Spring Garden Street and hedra
Lake those are real streets in
Philadelphia but I also think that they
may have been chosen for this scene as a
nod to Helen mirren's suspira's
mythology like I mentioned in my last
video on this this character is based on
the disparities the three nymphs of Dawn
and dusk tasked with protecting the
golden apple tree in Harris Garden
another story from Greek mythology the
Judgment of Paris tells the story of
Eris the goddess of Discord who decided
to cause drama at the wedding of pelea
synthetis she threw a golden apple
inscribed with two the fairest one into
the part Hera Athena and Aphrodite
fought over which of them was the
prettiest the results of which led to
the start of the Trojan War likewise
Calypso is using her Golden Apple to sew
Discord in Philly outside of Sam
Castle's Stakes Helen Mirren a 77 year
old woman absolutely kicked shazam's ass
although the trailer prefaces the scene
with we will annihilate everything and
finishes it with a kick to the chest the
former trailer featured Billy's Fast and
the Furious joke here making the scene
appear a lot more light-hearted this
version makes it clear that hispara and
Calypso are not here to F around and
talk about Dominic Toretto they're at
war with the shazamoli because they
believed that the kids stole the power
from the gods and they have the repaired
staff kind of makes them Unstoppable
next we see what I like to call the
Shazam manual glowing with lightning
Billy gives us a quick recap from the
last movie a wizard gave him powers and
then his friends got powers and now
they're a team albate a team that has
recently started to move in separate
directions this clip is actually from
the first Shazam when Billy jumps off
the roof of his biological mother's
apartment building and activates his
powers but despite seemingly drifting
apart the Shazam really comes together
for this battle on the Ben Franklin
Bridge as they arrive Drake's 2013 Bop
Started From The Bottom begins to play
symbolizing how far this ragtag group of
foster kids have come on their journey
to superhero Dem with their chosen
family just before the dragon starts
shooting Fireballs at Market Street
beneath it see a catrido's pretzel track
this is a play on Tasty Cake a line of
snack foods manufactured in Philly that
share the same font behind it a tribute
to the Godfather of Gore horror director
Lucio falchi is displayed on a marquee
that reads falchi Billy warns the rest
of the shazamoly that the daughters of
Atlas are coming to hunt him down and
hespera explains a moment later the chi
Calypso and anthem are pretty upset by a
bunch of children stealing powers from
the gods from her jail cell she claims
that they ripped it from their father's
core which very apparently had negative
consequences for her and her Sisters in
this roof scene the spirit pulls Freddie
towards her like she's summoning the
force and a couple frames later we see
that her formerly monochrome black apple
is shedding its skin revealing its
golden hue underneath interestingly it
turns out the Calypso and Hesperia have
the power to rob the shazamilee of their
powers by shooting blue Lightning at
them from the end of the staff here we
see Freddy return to his child's self
after being struck by the blast and
later on in the trailer Mary zap midair
removing her powers and causing her to
fall from the sky luckily Shazam catches
her unfortunately it looks like she
drops the golden apple she must have
stolen from the daughters towards the
end of the trailer we also see Mary
Eugene and Darla sitting in the grass in
their normal bodies and I think that
they might be powered down in this scene
too as I mentioned in my last trailer
breakdown the Shazam only has a pretty
cool t-shirt collection Freddy has a
Batman and Robin shirt with an actual
bat and an actual Robin printed on it
Billy's wearing a Goonies shirt Eugene
has on an iconoclast Robin shirt and
Freddie is seen later in the trailer
wearing a white Tree of Gondor shirt
back to the action the wizard warned the
Shazam only that our world won't survive
what the daughters have coming for us
Calypso's Dragon fires blue flame breath
and once again 77 year old Helen Mirren
kicked shazam's ass but don't worry
despite the city-wide distraction we see
that Billy does get a hold of the staff
at some point during their battle based
on the small amount of singing to his
shirt I'd say that this takes place
towards the beginning of Billy's fight
with the dragon as Calypso rides her
Dragon through the cityscape Billy calls
her Khaleesi referencing Daenerys
Targaryen from Game of Thrones he hurls
himself directly at the dragon's torso
sending it flying through an entire
building okay the last time Zod and
Superman flew through a building Ben
Affleck got like really upset isn't this
the exact scenario that caused dawn of
Martha's
Billy's gonna be so grounded when the
Justice League finds out do you get
really excited to watch a new show or
movie only to find that it's not
available in your country RR made me
more curious about what's going on in
Bollywood but most of that stuff isn't
available in the US unless you're using
nordvpn with nordvpn I can switch my
virtual location on my device with one
click letting me access streaming
services from over 60 countries at no
extra cost this opens up a smorgasbord
of stuff to watch that I wouldn't
normally be able to without nordvpn
nordvpn is also the fastest VPN out
there so you won't have to sacrifice
speed for the sake of your shows it's
what we use at the new Rockstar's
offices in the Lamy to sell you it is
fast for the price of one cup of coffee
a month I get to have premium cyber
security on six devices and gain access
to streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost it's also
available on every platform to grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal go to nordvpn
Slash new rockstars to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift card VPN has a 30 day money
back guarantee so you can try nordv can
completely risk-free just click the link
in the description to get started next
we see Anthea performing the same spell
as in the last trailer she's holding her
hands straight out in front of her where
you can see a venn diagram-esque symbol
glowing on her open Palms a frame later
we see ampy addressed in a yellow cape
and metal Bangles going head-to-head
with Calypso she's holding her arms in
the same position and either Calypso
shoots her backwards or her magic
propels her away from that scary ass
dragon now here's my question what is
going on with all of these moving
buildings and other structures we have
some kind of Multiverse and Madness
situation on our hands are they somehow
battling in an alternate plane of
reality or are the daughters somehow
physically warping our world Beyond just
the dragon's destruction is the golden
apple causing this surely blowing up a
stadium with roots can't be this
mcguffin's only use is the Apple what's
causing reality to break apart like this
moments later the daughters kidnap
Freddy on what looks like a floating
piece of debris levitating him high
above the city although Shazam and the
others try to go after him the daughter
seal Philadelphia or or possibly even
the whole planet in a giant bubble that
prevents you from exiting the atmosphere
I'm more inclined to believe that this
Dome only surrounds Philly however due
to the shot where we see the bridge
bisected by it I'm personally thinking
of it kind of like Wanda's hex which
only surrounded the perimeter of
Westview Philly begs the lizard to take
his powers back hoping to put an end to
the destruction but the wizard reminds
him that it took him like forever to
find a new champion and that Billy knows
what he has to do I think that this is a
hint that Billy might die at some point
during the movie if he can't give his
powers Away by having the wizard
transfer them to his pharaoh and Calypso
he might have to sacrifice his life to
save his family and the rest of the
world I think that's what he's doing
when he shows up at the stadium for a
night fight with Calypso and her Dragon
check out his suit when he first arrives
only part of it is burnt a few frames
later in the trailer we see his suit
almost completely charred likely towards
the end of their fight even though I
suspect that he might lose he does get
in a sweet sweet uppercut to that
dragon's jaw then we see a close-up of
the structure I think is Mount Olympus
flanked with two statues of Warriors out
front and three smaller statues in the
back well I'm not sure exactly who these
Warriors might be from this quick little
clip because there are hundreds of
possible candidates from Greek mythology
I'm pretty certain that the statues in
the back represent the three daughters
of Atlas espara Calypso and Anthea
lastly we gotta talk about those
mythical creatures we don't just have
dragons and gods here folks we've got
manticores minotaurs and black unicorns
although I think the unicorns are more
tame than the manticores and minotaurs
while the kids ride these Majestic
Mythic horses through the city the other
creatures are terrorizing civilians
personally I'm placing all my bets on
the Manticore he's gonna be the real
star of Shazam 2. follow me on Instagram
and Twitter whitneypuppy follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]